and who are you you're not supposed to be able to
do that and he just did it man he's a magician on
his feet what's an exclamation point really weak
in stock by Maro out top Theodor down low backand
Maro scores how about that Jonathan Marsh is
so creative getting the puck to the net him
and theor great stick by eel that creates the
turnover there's the little give and go then
quick play by Marsha so before heart can get set
he just spins probably reading pass on this but
he goes between the pads with the backhand spin
move it'll be interesting to see if he lets her
go he's got a rocket first career penalty shot
for sprong and it's a goal Daniel sprong wow Red
Wings lead it one to nothing did he ever put
the yo-yo to sleep on that one oh what a move
by strong Henrik zberg Nick cronwell like that
duson the B CH to paner cross sight TR now Guston
tro trying to get it scores and his streak his 15
consecutive game to start the season the longest
ever by a New York Ranger this Puck Movement by
the Rangers is just absolutely superb back and
forth cross the ice and eventually paner will get
it back after about the fifth pass and vanak just
simply can't get over there in time and hackin
by the defenseman cutting from the corner through
the slot and just stayed wide Marchman he'll flip
it in front caught nicely just score what a play
terrific Trap by San on the feet in front marman
little saier himself and then a fade away Dagger
from Tyler s over the short side shoulder Eric
Johnson racing after the aformentioned getting
around Seth Jones scor Johnson picks it up drops
his shoulder steps by Jones he's contested on
the far side and he just takes and fires this
one high to the net and it beat morazzi short
side looks like it goes crossbar bar in mazic
looking on how did that happen and who are you
you're not supposed to be able to do that and he
just did it now he gets it back to Hughes lots of
traffic in front as Quinn Hughes cuts across the
high slot now goes wide on zerland Hughes shoots
he scor this ridiculous agility here for Quinn
Hughes we see him time and again just dust the
forward at the top of the circle now watch as
he's got hurdle and then vland they can't stay
with him and Blackwood flattens out Quinn Hughes
doesn't need much room and it's in the net man
he's a magician on his feet disrupted zaka can't
clear it it stays in it's still on side heel to
CRA what a finish here 7 Seconds standing across
oh they scored that's the play right there that's
an empty net goal gone away that was as close
as you get Victor kept it in right at the blue
L and then as the play develops stammer and the
great scorers stay away stay patient unreal 4.8
seconds to go that one's going to count Chuck TI
out head for stla winding it is Tim stla lost the
edge speeds it back and Chuck scores what a fe
by spla and kachu got his second this is a crazy
play there probably should have been a penalty
call to have Brink it and when everybody had
their back turned I mean this a pass and a half
right onto the tape of kachuck who goes whoa look
what I got and and he says thank you very much
now it's neander the other way he's got tharus
with him in comes neander tries him scores what a
great defensive play Morgan Riley comes across on
the slide and then the rest is done by number
88 and you let her just looking where's my for
there he is he can't P it with me stick that leg
out drive across so much going on there in such
tight spaces he makes it look so easy for the
awareness to know flurry's comeing with a stick
to chop it back up short side to end the game
serson drops it back comes B with a pass AC he
BS it in TI with an incredible hand play BR Vera
oh what a goal he's got a wait for it to drop and
he does weighs High chokes down on the blade more
control and bats it past a scrawling James Rymer
home run swing walk off is what it is for Tim C
oh that's brilliant brilliant who seconds left in
overtime set ahead Here Comes Kim busting through
shoot and stars Joel kimy R he split the D he
fires it right through the body of do stall for
his first goal as a Colorado Avalanche and giat
the speed it's noticeable out here just those
towards a net battles for a pocket and that's
got to feel good he worked incredibly hard toin
in shot tonight by SK the rebound they score
Alexander wber wber going to the backand Skinner
thinks he's keeping it that way he stops forehand
move back all the way around being able to stop
and spin back on his forehand great scoring play
by Alexander wber Great Net fun presence here's
rust racing back in back Ander scor Brian Russ
all kinds of speed down that Wing gives him a
little shoulder drop shoulder Shake forehand
to backhand for his eighth goal of the year Brian
R Us continues to play well and play Hot to start
this season Jake smiling he's going you kidding
me Cory Perry he's got some help try to swing it
across in front Sol of that tick tac toe and it's
Cory Perry who finishes off a brilliant Chicago
setup Dickinson is going to deflect this Puck over
towards Cory Perry who's now standing a foot and a
half from the net there's no chance for Johanson
there as Cory Perry is tied this game at two it
ships it to Center try to break in he's got space
yes he OED it to the for half score what a goal
it's a good play by ul and to pop it out in that
zone he has a tremendous shot a far above average
shot and he goes right to it full confidence as
soon as he settles the puck here he's going top
shell goodish got a stick on it now lerina picks
it up again moena out in front he scores quick
Puck movement in behind a little give and go royen
back to Mundell back to lyer Anon and watch where
Gibson is Gibson's looking on the other side of
the net and the puck behind him AO comes up with
an intercept drop this one back Jarvis terine and
AO they score Tick T tied Carolina love the way
they stacked up AO and Company in the neutral zone
Jarvis drops it to him in a brilliant pass and the
guy that stacked up gets himself to a soft area
gos table will find him and ties the hockey game
of walstrom and now it's B pil with a B of R
Pilla in scores oh my this has highlight all
over it what a pass by cadri to use the boards as
a passer to find pil going in what a ball oh my I
mean he outweighs theen and then throws it right
up high and that's just a work of art all the way
from their own Zone all the way into the goal coov
swirls back here's Hond headman hangs on K back
and forth across St go score what a goal watch
this passing sequence cooch off the point point
back to coov then across the stamco Bang Bang
bang bang in the net Jo moves in here's VC Dred
it off save he strong Sam Vincent troch stayed on
the ice while his line mates were changing and so
were the Devils he waits and now the drop pass
and here come the fresh forward on the ice and
what a play by Jimmy beey after pitl took the shot
Beezy wouldn't quit on the play goes to the net
watch how he stops and just turns and puts it in
the empty side broken up in a break short and to
break kempe in DS score it starts with stick
on Puck kempe anticipated he has a couple of
stick handles and watch the goal tender he loses
his balance there he can't keep up with the puck
so he doesn't know where it is he almost Falls
forward while moving backward kicks lead three
to nothing forced back board to drive SLE what
timer score M DAV it from the spot where dry CLE
usually buries it the puck ends up in the hands of
dry SLE and he finds Conor mcav finds that quiet
ice literally on the goal line and beats fski to
the short side with a great one time ponok Saka
and what a creative pass by David ponok looking
to tie this hogey game he's looking to beat the
goal tender by himself but instead he drags him
out of the crease area to his left and he makes
a back pass to zaka tape to tape who just one
times it short-handed here's Den know for more
streaking to the right Circle a shot he's SC this
play starts with the speed of the feet and ends
with the quickness of the hands and at the last
second it looks like Trevor's going to take it
wide watch this one quick move there to the inside
forehand up top all in one motion Tempe will get
it in deep kobitar in quickly coyotes turn it over
Byfield to his backand feeds it across score on J
kopar on another great set up by Quinton Byfield
you'll see a dip shoulder by Quinton Byfield watch
the swoop right there the pulling drag I have to
give Andre credit too because it's a crossbody
one- timer the puck goes all the way in front of
them he has to shoot it all in one [Music] motion